thank you sir how many cocktails you can
drink during the
meal however they bring me
natalie's thoughts were all over her
face
as she met uncle bo in person for the
first time
after being the reason mike kicked him
out of the house
now this little meet-up honestly it had
me on the edge of my seat
just hoping that she wouldn't say
anything
too judgmental where did you leave you
moved yes
you don't like his house yeah i don't
know no
no i mean good really
natalie really we're gonna talk about it
plus we also have to talk about brandon
it seems like one night with julia gave
him some courage
because he finally put his foot down to
his mom
about spending one-on-one time with
his fiancee we've got lots more to see
before tonight when we go to dinner
yeah i kind of got plans for us i got
this reservation somewhere
yes betty was shocked
hey 90 day fans fam it's melicia
i hope you are enjoying the holiday
season
let's go ahead and get into the biggest
musty moments
from the latest episode of 90 day fiance
mike and natalie these two spent a
romantic
night together in seattle at this really
nice hotel
and natalie she was obviously very
pleased
in a number of ways me and mike were
having
ups and downs but when it comes for
our sexual relationship we only have ups
okay well i'm not sure how long these
ups are gonna last for them because
although it was
sweet it seems as if mike knew
he had to pull out all the stops on
night one
to prime natalie for all these
uncomfortable moments
she would have in store like moment
number one before they left the hotel
mike told natalie
that they are going to meet uncle beau
who was in the city
aka the man who she demanded
to be kicked out of the house before she
arrived oh it's a couple
yeah jazz what are you guys doing
[Music]
how you been buddy how's everything
going
i'd like you to be natalie
[Music]
i like you all so cool uncomfortable
so stylish i was actually really
impressed
by how natalie introduced herself to
uncle beau
there was an awkward moment
where she was kind of stuck i guess she
was taking it all in
but it didn't last for too long and look
we can think whatever we want about
uncle beau he still deserves to be
treated with kindness and respect
like every human and natalie gave him
that
but there were also a few moments where
she could not
hold her tongue where did you leave you
moved yes
you didn't exist yeah i don't live up
there no more no
no i mean good
i mean me and michael need our personal
space you know so that's fine i'm sorry
for that
you're fine where are you now dude down
the road
no in general yeah well what
you guys are both confusing each other
now
he's a huh and she's wet yeah huh where
are we talking about how
what for because of my english i
couldn't really understand what he talks
but i thought that he's great man
[Music]
he's just smiling and happy and shiny
but i will not invite bo back to the
house
you know it's so ironic that she brought
up the house
because that leads us to uncomfortable
moment
number two for natalie the moment she
saw her new home
for the first time based off of her
reaction
it doesn't seem like the ups in the
bedroom
are gonna help with this one this house
looks like from movia
it's like from coromos i just hate
horror movies
it's time to get snowy and wet
come on in this is the mud room
it's all georgia yeah you get always
muddy in here
welcome home glove take your bag
let me see let's see
is this what you were expecting no i
don't know it just
no i mean the house is really small and
the voice
is very very cold i find it so
interesting
that this is a house uncle beau loved
and he got kicked out because of her and
she hates it
i don't necessarily think natalie is
being ungrateful
but i do think mike might have set
himself up with the hotel
it made her expectations too high
you know sometimes it is best just to
give people the real
deal up front so they don't have time to
fantasize
about something else because now
natalie's sitting over here
looking like she's about to cry i flew
10 000 miles
i'm leaving my mom i'm living my city
i'm leaving everything behind
and mike wasn't prepared house is not
clean
it's not comfortable it's cold
i don't even have marine gear back
[Music]
it's hot hey it's hard but
you gotta live with the decisions you
make all right
let's move on to one of my favorite
couples
brandon and julia during her first
morning in america
julia woke up to brandon bringing her
coffee and breakfast
which was cute but the cuteness
went away the moment he told her she had
three minutes to get ready because
they're on his mom's schedule
betty would have had to add a zero
behind that three
for me yesterday is your parents all day
yesterday last year's parents
i know it's okay put up with them a
little bit more
and next we go home and every day is
david's parents
yes and they basically put up them even
more
julia's face was my reaction
exactly put up with them even more
that's scary she did make it a point to
tell brandon
that if he doesn't talk to his mom about
them being able to sleep in the same
room
when they get back to the house she is
going home
to russia might just save in a different
room because she
thinks this is helpful don't have baby
this is not help
if you stay different room of course you
have sex but
different place got a lot of sleep
that's more
but that's not what i wanted to hear
i'm just saying we had a really big day
of uh sightseeing planned
but julia's a little jet-lagged and they
slept late this morning so
we got a little bit later start than we
wanted betty
relax as a family they ended up having
a really good time out sightseeing
we learned that julia loves and i mean
loves
her selfie stick i love my selfie stick
because
i everywhere want picture and
selfie stick everywhere with me because
say one people jealous man look at
picture when i say america
i think i'm like i'm stay america are
you not bye bye
look at me when i am when are you at
least she's honest about it
as brandon's mom was trying to spit out
facts about the washington monument
julia was busy posing for the camera yes
yes stop right the camera loves you
i can see my mom kind of rolling her
eyes every time julia's taking a selfie
but
whatever that's what julia does
she wants us to take photos together and
then i need to pack up
and make sure i get some beautiful shots
of her
we may get up to the monument at some
point yeah maybe this sometimes it
should be
good come on we got more to see
come on i just want to say kudos to
brandon
for being a great photographer and a
great height man
he was on point fast forward he did pull
his mom aside
to see if she would come around on them
being able to stay in the same room
together
once they get home but she didn't budge
she didn't and honestly i didn't expect
her to
what i also didn't expect was for
brandon to
put his foot down about taking julia out
to dinner
later that night well when we finish uh
eating we can head over to
the link memorial and then past that's
the jefferson memorial
then there's the korean war memorial
we've got lots more to see before
tonight when we go to dinner actually i
was uh kind of thinking we'd head back
now
yeah i kind of got plans for us i got
this reservation somewhere
if that's you with me for dinner i guess
so that's okay
yeah i guess it is what it is okay
okay mom and dad it's not like he just
told you you couldn't come to his
wedding
it's just dinner just dinner all right
next week on 90 day fiance julia finally
makes it to her new home
on the farm all my life live city and
one [ __ ] farm
julia i can't wait to see that
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
because we are covering it all i'll see
you next time
you